osy is a stage of embryonic development
that occurs be after the morula stage
and precedes the implantation in the
uterus so this is day Zero where the
fertilization takes place generally the
blastos stage is 5 to 6 day after the
fertilization so in this stage there are
distinct cellular layers so first of all
the outer layer is known as stropas as
this stage and the inner layer is known
as Inner Cell Mass within one day these
structures rapidly grows and
differentiates into other structures and
cellular layers so now the trophoblast
is distinct in terms of cytotrophoblast
and cot
trophoblast and the Inner Cell Mass gets
differentiated into hypoblast and the AP
blast remember AP blast is the future
embryo and this condition is known as
bilaminar embryonic disk